[Music]
dream job new I want to dream job you
have a dream job job
submitted by Joe malian coach what are
the coaching Joe feet binding Cancun is
hiring someone to document their
experience of the city for $10,000 a
month I did one for Taiwan I could do it
for cuttin cuttin wait what
that's it again cuz you were just not
reading it Cancun is hiring someone to
document their experience of the city
for $10,000 a month isn't that every
vlogger in the world yeah but only a few
vloggers take the cinematic steps to
make a place look beautiful put your
hands down because David sign up yeah
how do I sign up it is ah you go go on
their website and sign up they should
they should sign all of us because you
could do the party thing what can you
could do the food thing I'll just join
on everybody's thing you could bring
Tyga you could bring Isaac and KC and
then do like a older family thing to
apply candidates need to create a
one-minute video explaining why they are
the experience officer candidate winner
you have to do you have to do this by
December 17th and then the videos will
be then voted by the public and then
boiled down to a short list of 100
candidates by Cancun comm which is the
travel company arranging this whole
thing and then so they will have a panel
and then they will pick a winning
candidate I
why don't you do that sounds dope well I
don't even tell you the rest of the
details is really awesome so you already
ready for cat could you had that
sunbrella you been a cat yeah I was
watching my family vlogs I want to go
again your family vlogs yeah who belongs
in their family I like my dad and my
grandpa were recording like I've done
the airport and I was like oh I should
edit this even though it's little Bri
yeah it was really fun yeah I love
traveling
I love documenting things however you
like it I could do a cinematic if you
prefer I could just take the time bring
a small crew with me I'll make it happen
just create this one-minute video and
you have popularity so then you can get
your video to be number one how the
dollars a month Porter 5water doing this
for and that's the best part
so Cancun comm they are trying to find
an experienced officer right and so the
this officer will get to experience all
the hotels excursions
everything for ten thousand dollars a
month for six months starting in March
of 2018 wow that's really good
so you had all the weed and hookers that
you want literally everything Cancun has
to offer this rob debauchery yes oh
that's late night dinners with the
cartels do they have tea in Canton
what the the participant whoever wins
they will need to create create edit and
promote content that shows everything
that they're doing in Cancun and
everything that just everything that
they have to offer everything every
coconut live like constantly updating
monkey petting ziplining another monkey
I feel like well get whatever you're
doing like yeah that's your whole job
for six months is just constantly
telling like just eating Paco's today
pretty much what we do on the view we
have we do it every every single day I
like to store my [ __ ] get it right
correct cousin you saying sorry
developing story cousin young che I
don't like to just put it like out there
you're gonna run out of [ __ ] you just do
something new every day you're getting
$10,000 you know you're good this is
like for people who are constantly on
social media see this is this is what's
up for you if you're gonna snap chat
24/7 like between his dream job yeah
yeah I mean like she does that all the
time she be good at that yeah I'm not
good at that
imagine all the model pictures you could
take there and any time a natural
disaster happens you can talk about all
that and actually be there like those
[ __ ] that aren't even like anything
pray for Cancun with your ass yep and
you'll actually be the disasters behind
you
yeah perfect why is this world so
corrupt you could be in a bikini while
there's a tsunami happening make sure
you Archer ass and make it sexy yeah
perfect
the only requirements is that the winner
has to be fluent in English and 18 and
over that's it really cuz I'm quite
fluent in English that already [ __ ]
most of us up not that fluent in English
I speak English good
americano thank you yeah I gotta go have
like a real like Mexican experience
that's true cuz I only been at equine
I know we got a house like a little JIT
what dude where we get to see like the
Aztec [ __ ] the mines
you'll eat all the really good food
Mexico is a place where I hand out my
own old clothes that's why it's not like
I haven't seen the history and the fun
no no or a lot of people don't ever get
to see the really beautiful side of the
country because they only get to meet
just TJ or like Cabo or Cancun which and
Ensenada Cruz was just like going to LA
yeah exactly there's like you don't
really get to see that go and how
beautiful the whole culture and
everything the beautiful parts of Mexico
can you fly directly there is there like
an airport in Mexico City or something
what kind of beautiful town look at Oh
as tech stuff I want to see ancient
Mexico yeah or in like Merida my sister
lives there and they have Herman
thinking you're so cool about world
history the only reason why I know about
all this Aztec all of a sudden I just
play a game called Age of Empires Yeah
right
and so that game actually helped me out
on my world history test a lot because
it's like historically accurate and
they're very very specific I love it
helped me out on my world history test
but we're going over like like a stick
in Mayan culture cousin gave me a
[ __ ] saucy - that's games correct
then you get a lot of nerd rage yes oh
that's right yeah you have to be
accurate or else they start getting
really angry I love the age of empires I
never played by the rules I always add
all the cheat codes so I could just
build and destroy kill people yeah but I
love the story they even teach you the
story of Joan of Arc when you go to like
that story here on campaign mode yeah
it's pretty [ __ ] awesome man
knowledge and games did you play the
Korean dynasty where people have a
special thing and their special thing
was like the submarine submarine yep
they have all this likes historically
accurate like [ __ ] like military
weaponry to like you didn't even know
that [ __ ] who's been a can't come hear
me what is it like tell me it's so
beautiful I know it's funny on Casey
Casey and I went
a long time ago actually I think like
lightning me [ __ ] yeah one zip like we
did and it was really fun but I thought
I found it really funny because every
time I start speaking Spanish people
would be like like they were ready to
just only speak English because I feel
like everybody torch the area their main
thing is tourism like they don't but
they don't have Mexican tourists in
Mexico that's what I was thinking too
late there should be a lot of Mexicans
here but then every time I think it's
because I was with Casey and so they
just are angry soon I know but then
because they would see I'm with him and
then I'd be speaking Spanish and be like
that's like Kabul when he goes to Taco
Bell he starts trying to speak Spanish
to [ __ ] talk yeah speak Spanish now
feluccas he lived in Ecuador for two
years why would he go to Taco Bell this
I don't know but that did it at a Del
Taco - and there's a girl looks at her
straight if she goes I don't speak
Spanish maybe King Taco cuz everyone
speaks Spanish and King top even the
numbers don't even speak English I know
the King talk was like a soccer yeah
with ania what is that window many days
did you write dolphins and can't cook
yeah we did we did I know and we should
hold on to the dolphin wing I mean the
the dolphin wing defense yeah that was
an experience I had always wanted to try
my whole life no but there was a lady
next to me that the dolphin did kind of
like no it's only by chance that you
don't get [ __ ] in the ass by a dolphin
it's based on their mood they're like no
they're really they seemed like they
were happy because it was open water it
wasn't like a pool or anything it was
like they were in the ocean it was just
kind of fenced off
banished shits on his face so I was like
because you know there's a lot of people
like how do you feel about the whole I'm
not doing it she doesn't like them in
captivity she doesn't believe in that
[ __ ] like the safari [ __ ] where you're
in the cage and you're in
[ __ ] what if you're swimming at the
beach and that a dolphin comes up to you
in the wild and lets you ride them yeah
that's dope
that would never happen yeah that would
be dead but yeah I would I would want to
like interact with it I don't know if I
would write it I don't know enough about
it to want to write it no the whole
writing thing it was just a one or it
was like the final part of the whole
experience mainly it was just like them
getting like treats out of much is that
whole experience it was expensive I
don't remember but I remember thinking
like this is a lot I want to put a
saddle on a dolphin and ride them stop
and that I'll go to the sunset I saw a
lot of dolphins like a week ago I when I
was at the beach and then they were just
going like these in the way you're in LA
yeah there's a lot in Torrance being on
the beach the Pacific Highway and I saw
will you call a herd of a pack alright
whatever up dolphins I saw their fins
just pop up yeah and then they go like
this they're probably gay Ganga dolphins
come out I saw I saw eight of them Wow
don't be crazy though [ __ ] them though
why group of doctors will be pod a pod
that's what it is often pod the only
thing I like of dump is one is when I
see like blue planet and they're
speeding next to them and you see them
going to caliphal was so [ __ ]
graceful and beautiful but then I hear
they can even kill sharks and then
[ __ ] rape their own kind
and I saw them rape an actual human
woman woman like it all up in a [ __ ] is
it out yeah cuz they get the nose yeah I
think you [ __ ] Jam up in their [ __ ]
[ __ ] cuz they I don't know what it is
about them but they had this just really
Restless me but they also but they but
they also save people like there's
stories of people like oh no they're
about to get attacked yeah anything
comes in and let me save it's a mermaid
Joe [ __ ] porpoise I'm saying it sounds
very similar I think there's this
ancient story about how the dolphins our
our and in dolphins are the humans of
the sea and Poseidon is their Lord and
then the humans are the humans of the
land
and I don't know who our Lord is but
this is oh yeah Zeus but then the
Dolphins are supposed to be like the
humans of the water then I think they
are if we could just communicate to them
I think we found another type of use
[Music]